side a whistle on the warriors  yeah at the end of it right there it  doesn't take much when you have an  injury like that i mean you can sit down  wrong  brian and and feel the pain on that one  luckily steph was able to get up and  kind of run it off  right in and out and look at wiggins the  effort to run it down  curry three-pointer for stephen curry  tailbone injured comes right back  wiggins kept it alive curry cash  two point stephen curry trying to shake  one of the best defenders in the game  that quick release cash money  stephen curry 89 83 bucks  ending without fouling at a beautiful  defensive stand right there by the  golden state warriors  stephen curry goes for four